eigentlich wollte ich heute eine
glücksrad häkel challenge mit rob
hochladen jedoch aus aktuellem anlass
ich glaube die wissen worum es geht ich
habe vor gut zwei wochen die luca pizza
2 in kooperation mit dem pizza
produzenten gustavo musste raus gebracht
das ist einfach eine pizza prosciutto di
es in rewe und edeka märkten in
deutschland zu kaufen gibt gestern
morgen bekam ich dann allerdings um 9
uhr 20 die nachricht dass
kunststoffteile auf der lu kapitza 2
sein können in der mitteilung die ich
zugeschickt bekommen habe stand genauer
drin die franko fresko gmbh hat umgehend
reagiert und den betroffenen artikel
bereits aus dem verkauf nehmen lassen
betroffen sind rewe märkte in den
bundesländern bayern hessen und
rheinland-pfalz es geht hier nämlich
nicht um alle pizzen sondern es geht um
405 pizzen mit dem
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum 13 05 2009 10
und der losnummer 288 und betroffen sind
auch lediglich rewe märkte also nicht
edeka märkte und auch nur rewe märkte in
den bundesländern hessen bayern und
rheinland-pfalz bitte so
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass ihr
tatsächlich einer dieser besitzen
erwischt haben sollte wendet euch bitte
direkt an gustavo gusto hier info at
gustavo co.com und ich habe euch die
mailadresse und nochmal die beschreibung
gepackt also dass hier erst mal vorab
die ganzen fakten und so ein bisschen
kontext zu schaffen was gerade überhaupt
abgeht halte ich diese mitteilung
erhalten habe weil ich gerade auf dem
weg zur ob also einem kumpel von mir
weil wir uns verabredet hatten für
einige stunden um videos aufzunehmen
zwischenzeit ist unsere new business
vice president von studio 1 70 also
meinem management nach münchen geflogen
zu gustavo gust worum genauere umstände
ab zu kennen und um genau zu
hinterfragen wie das einerseits
passieren konnte und wie wir nun am
besten vorgehen
daraufhin hatten wir um 14 uhr einen
großen call mit allen beteiligten
parteien bei der new kapitza 2 also mit
dem prosieben leisten singen mit gustavo
gusto mit studie 73 mit mir und um
einfach herauszufinden
die das ganze passieren konnte um
genauere informationen über die
betroffenen pizzen zu bekommen und um
einfach abzuklären wie wir nun weiterhin
vorgehen werden wir haben
neben verfasst dass sich einige stunden
später auf instagram und snapshot
veröffentlicht habe ich lerne das euch
hier mal ein leider muss ich euch
mitteilen dass es beim
herstellungsprozess der luca pizza 2 ein
mitarbeiter fehler beim produzenten
gustav augusto gab auf einigen wenigen
männer pizzen können sich
kunststoffteile befinden
dies betrifft nur eine verschwindend
geringe anzahl an sitzen da der fehler
sofort bemerkt wurde euer wohlbefinden
hat die allerhöchste priorität von daher
haben wir uns direkt zu einem rückruf
entschlossen und genau diese wenigen
pizzen komplett aus dem verkauf genommen
der rückruf betrifft eine palette mit
405 pizzen die anrede ausgeliefert
wurden betroffen sind ausschließlich
pizzen mit dem mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
13 05 2009 10 und der losnummer 288 für
den unwahrscheinlichen fall dass ihr
tatsächlich eine dieser wenigen
betroffenen pizzen erwischt haben
solltet wendet euch bitte direkt an
gustavo musste unter info at bus da
wusste punkt kommen sie kümmern sich
dann umgehend um euch ich bin über
diesen vorfall genau sogar rasch wie ihr
und extrem unglücklich damit die luca
pizza extrem am herzen liegt es tut mir
unsagbar leid und glaubt mir wir
befinden uns gerade in ernsten gespräch
mit gustavo gusto in diesem statement
wurden alle informationen so gebündelt
wie es nur eben gegen zusammengefasst um
einfach klar zu machen hey das war keine
absicht es geht wirklich nur um diese
405 pizzen aber wenn ihr einer dieser
405.000 erwischt haben solltet meldet
euch bitte direkt bei uns weil ganz
ehrlich das kann einfach nicht sein ich
denke jeder mensch mit klarem verstand
sollte wissen dass wir nicht absichtlich
plastik drauf getan haben und dass nicht
wie ich da jetzt irgendwie an der
produktion stehe unter plastik drüber
gestolpert habe oder so sondern das war
wirklich ein einzelner mitarbeiter
fehler beim produzenten gustavo gusto
deswegen das ganze halt leider passiert
so groove aktion passieren alltäglich da
kann man nichts gegen tun wenn mal ein
fehler passiert in der produktion oder
so das kann man nie ganz verhindern ist
allerdings wirklich sehr sehr
enttäuschend für mich genauso wie für
euch dass es jetzt bei der luca pizza
zwei auch so gekommen ist wie gesagt
haben wir direkt reagiert und alle
pizzen aus dem verkauf genommen falls
sie allerdings wie gesagt trotzdem so
eine pizza haben solltet ihr noch mal
die emailadresse und
melden können doch allgemein wenn ihr
eine luca peter 2 gekauft haben sollte
die nicht das mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
13 05 2009 10 aufweist dementsprechend
nicht zu diesen erwähnten 405 pizzen
gehört habt ihr trotzdem die möglichkeit
auch ohne kassenbon in euren rewe markt
zu gehen und die pizza zurück geben zu
lassen
übrigens sorry falls sie mich an einigen
stellen hierfür hat
aber für mich also ich zitter seit einem
tag eigentlich nur noch das ist auch für
mich also ihr müsst wirklich verstehen
dieses luca pizza zwei projekte das war
für mich so das ding eigentlich dieses
jahr und schrott ist halt scheiße kann
man muss man so sagen ich möchte mich an
der stelle bei simon ungedanken der ein
video dazu heute hochgeladen hat simon
hat in seinem video ganz klar gesagt
dass es natürlich nicht meine schuld war
dass dort plastikteilchen auf die pizza
gekommen sind das war wirklich wie
gesagt einen produzenten fehler das war
ein mitarbeiter der da ein bisschen halt
und nachts einfach sage ich mal
aber und damit hat sie man auf jeden
fall rechts ich hätte euch früher
informieren müssen einerseits und auf
mehr
also hier auf youtube halt auch noch
informieren müssen
also ich bin ganz ehrlich ich war bei
rob und wir haben videos aufgenommen und
ich dachte hey die 405 pizzen weil das
war zudem stand meine mein aktueller ich
hoffe ich kann ich für richtig reden
irgendwie zu dem zeitpunkt als nicht bei
rohwaren und wir die videos aufgenommen
haben war ich in guter stimmung weil ich
dachte okay es ist scheiße passiert
heute morgen aber die pizzen sind schon
auch rückweg und blabla und wir haben's
zurückgerufen doch dann hat das ganze so
hohe wellen geschlagen
also hier schaut euch das an ist also
ich kann er auf zählen welches magazin
nicht darüber berichtet hat was
allerdings auch vollkommen richtig ist
und ich bin dankbar für jeden der
darüber sagen ich mal ein video gemacht
hat war herr newstime über simon
umgebaut ans verbot auch wenn er mich an
vielen stellen beleidigt hat ihren bitte
versteht dass es nicht meine absicht war
das der plastikteile drauf sind aber
trotzdem danke dass du informiert hast
und den zuschauern halt gesagt hast was
gerade abgeht mit der lupe der gestrige
tag und auch noch der heutige tag war
für mich einfach komplett verwirren
komplett durcheinander bringen ich
möchte einfach nur ihr gesagt leute euer
wohlbefinden hat für uns die
allerhöchste priorität
ja ich glaube ich habe es wirklich oft
genug gesagt hier findet alle
informationen bezüglich dieser
rückrufaktion und unser offizielles
statement bzw die pressemitteilung und
die mailadresse unternehmerisch werden
können unten in der kanal beschreibt und
verlinkt ihr findet die videos vom
tanzverbot simon und herrn used haben
nochmal da unten verlinkt ich habe euch
auch zwei drei sehr gute news artikel
dazu nochmal unten verlinkt ich möchte
einfach nur dass ihr versteht dass das
ganze was jetzt ja seit seit gestern
morgen passiert ist dass wir uns das
alle nicht gewünscht haben und dass ich
da genauso hart hart abgefuckt bin wir
an der stelle möchte mich auch nochmal
hier ganz offiziell noch mal am ende des
videos entschuldigen dass ich euch nicht
früher gesagt habe was abgeht die sache
war wirklich die vergangenheit hat mir
so ein bisschen gezeigt dass man lieber
abwarten sollte mit irgendeinem
voreiligen statement oder sowas als dass
man direkt was rausholen sollte wie
gesagt dass erst eine person von meinem
management nach münchen geflogen und hat
sich ein genaues bild von der lage
gemacht und wir haben die genauen
informationen
bezüglich des vorfalls bezüglich des
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatums bezüglich der
losnummer et cetera und der bundesländer
abgewartet und dann haben wir ein
statement veröffentlicht
und ja ich kann nicht mehr sagen als es
tut mir leid dass ich euch so spät
informiert habe ich kann sich oft genug
sagen aber falls sie einer dieser pizzen
haben solltet hier ist die e mail
adresse ich glaube ich drehe mich jetzt
auch im kreis
es ist für alle beteiligten parteien ist
das scheiße gerade und also im namen von
gustavo musst du im namen des
mitarbeiters dem der fehler leider
unterlaufen ist im namen von studie 71
und dem namen von prosieben und ganz
deutlich auch im namen von mir ein
großes großes sorry für die entstandenen
umstände
ja wir sehen uns morgen in einem neuen
hoffentlich unterhaltsam video